imaginen que tenemos tres cargas que se
encuentran juntas y se encuentran fijas
en su posición de alguna manera estas
cargas no se van a mover de su lugar
pero conocemos el valor de estas cargas
aquí tenemos un micro colon positivo por
aquí hay una carga de 5 micro colon es
positivo y aquí tenemos una carga de
menos 2 micro colores y una pregunta muy
común cuando tenemos este tipo de
situación es que si conocemos la
distancia entre las cargas cuál será el
potencial eléctrico total en cierto
punto y vamos a elegir este punto que se
encuentra en esta esquina vacía de aquí
así que queremos conocer el potencial
eléctrico en el punto p y ya que
conocemos la posición de cada una de las
cargas que van a crear un potencial
eléctrico en p vamos a usar la fórmula
para encontrar el potencial eléctrico
creado por una carga esta fórmula es de
igual a cal la constante eléctrica
multiplicada por q que es la carga que
está creando el potencial eléctrico
/ / r que es la distancia entre esta
carga hasta el punto en donde queremos
conocer el potencial eléctrico vean que
aquí tenemos tres cargas y todas crean
un potencial eléctrico en este punto p
por lo que lo que vamos a encontrar es
el total del potencial eléctrico en este
punto y para hacerlo vamos a encontrar
el potencial eléctrico individual creado
por cada una de estas cargas en este
punto p y luego las vamos a sumar en
otras palabras esta carga positiva de un
micro colom va a crear un valor de
potencial eléctrico en p y podemos usar
esta fórmula para encontrar cuál es este
valor por lo que el potencial eléctrico
creado por esta carga de un micro colom
positivo va a ser igual a acá que
siempre es 9 por 10 a la nueve
multiplicada por la carga que está
creando el potencial eléctrico que en
este caso es un micro colon positivo
micro significa 10 elevado a la menos 6
y la distancia entre esta carga y el
punto p
a hacer de 4 metros de aquí a acá
tenemos 4 metros y esto nos va a dar un
valor de 2 mil 250 giles por q lo que es
la unidad del potencial eléctrico pero
este es el potencial eléctrico creado
solamente por esta carga además un micro
culos en el punto p todas estas otras
cargas también van a crear su propio
potencial eléctrico en este punto por lo
que si queremos el total del potencial
eléctrico vamos a tener que encontrar la
contribución al potencial eléctrico de
cada una de estas cargas en este punto
así que el potencial eléctrico creado
por la carga de 5 micro colomos
positivos es también 9 por 10 a la 9
multiplicada por esta carga que es más 5
por 10 a la menos 6 entre la distancia
que hay de aquí al punto p y aquí hay
que tener cuidado ya que no voy a usar
la distancia de 3 metros ni la de 4
metros en esta fórmula tengo que usar la
distancia desde la carga
hasta el punto de interés que es esta
distancia de aquí a que va a ser igual
esto pues imagínense que aquí se está
creando un triángulo tenemos cuatro de
este lado y tres de este otro lado ya
que este lado es tres y para encontrar
la longitud de este lado lo que tenemos
que hacer es sacar la raíz cuadrada de
tres al cuadrado más cuatro al cuadrado
que es el teorema de pitágoras 916 es
igual a 25 y la raíz cuadrada de 25 es 5
por lo que aquí tenemos que son 5 metros
que van desde esta carga hasta este
punto p por lo que aquí ponemos 5 metros
y si usamos nuestra calculadora para
encontrar el resultado nos dan 9000
jules por colom y ahora sólo nos falta
calcular el potencial eléctrico de una
carga más ya que mi carga de menos 2
micro colom es también va a crear su
potencial eléctrico en este punto p por
lo que el potencial eléctrico creado por
esta carga de menos 2 micro colones va a
ser igual
a 9 x 10 a la 9 por la carga que crea el
potencial eléctrico que es de menos 2
por 10 a la menos 6 es cool oms y noten
que estamos incluyendo el signo de la
carga aquí cargas negativas crean
potencial eléctrico negativo en los
puntos del espacio que la rodean de la
misma manera que cargas positivas crean
potencial eléctrico positivo a su
alrededor por lo que tenemos que incluir
este negativo así que siempre recuerdan
incluir el signo de la carga pero no se
preocupen estos no son vectores éstas no
van a ser cantidades vectoriales del
potencial eléctrico el potencial
eléctrico no es una cantidad vectorial
es un escalar por lo que no va a tener
dirección de manera que aquí no tengo
que separar un vector en sus componentes
ni nada por el estilo
estos son solamente números en este
punto en el espacio y para encontrar el
total solamente vamos a sumar estas
cantidades pero no se van a sumar
correctamente sino incluimos el signo de
cada carga
que las cargas negativas crean un
potencial eléctrico negativo y la
distancia entre lo que dividimos esto es
la distancia de esta carga hasta este
punto que vimos por aquí que es de 3
metros si lo calculamos todo nos da
menos 6.000 jules por culo y ahora ya
tenemos todo lo que necesitamos para
encontrar el total de el potencial
eléctrico o el potencial eléctrico total
y de nuevo estos no son vectores por lo
que podemos literalmente sumarlos todos
ellos para obtener el potencial
eléctrico total así que el total del
potencial eléctrico en este punto p será
los valores del potencial eléctrico
creado por cada una de estas cargas de
forma individual así que tenemos dos mil
250 euros por colom más nueve mil soles
por culo más seis mil soles por colom
negativos y ponemos un paréntesis
alrededor de esto para que no nos
confunda y si sumamos dos mil doscientos
cincuenta más nueve mil menos seis mil
tendremos cinco mil doscientos cincuenta
jules por culo positivos
este es nuestro resultado en resumen
para encontrar el potencial eléctrico
total o el total del potencial eléctrico
en un punto en el espacio creado por
diferentes cargas podemos usar esta
fórmula para encontrar el potencial
eléctrico de cada carga individual en
este punto en el espacio y luego sumar
todos los valores del potencial
eléctrico creado por cada una de las
cargas para encontrar el total del
potencial eléctrico en este punto